bonjour à tous dans l'épisode 9 de
chroniques de profs que vous retrouverez
dans la description nos avions commencé
à faire l'histoire de la piraterie
on avait commencé à parler de la
piraterie dans l'antiquité puis on avait
abordé la période médiévale for the wind
et maintenant on va aborder l'époque
moderne et on va même un peu poussé vers
l'époque contemporaine
ne mettons pas la charrue avant les
boeufs on parle des phoques moderne ça
veut dire que je vais pouvoir parler
cette fois
mouais tu as l'air d'avoir le look qu'il
faut enfin en avant donc pour sa
deuxième partie de chroniques de profs
sur la piraterie
dans cette première partie nous allons
nous intéresser principalement à la mer
des caraïbes et à la mer de chine
on parle d'âge d'or de la piraterie
entre les années 1520 et 1720 la
piraterie dans la plus importante au
xviie siècle
en quoi consiste-t-elle exactement eh
bien on mène des attaques éclairs contre
des navires pour a fait tout ce qu'ils
ont et repartir aussi vite pour sa part
fois on fait croire qu'on est des
pauvres navire en détresse ont fait en
dehors de treuils et puis quand ils sont
assez proches bim et samara à eux ils
sont déjà dans la mouise parfois des
pirates s'attaquent aussi à des villes
côtières d'amérique du sud
pour cela il leur arrive de rassembler
plusieurs navires qui salit le temps
d'une attaque on connaît les pirates des
caraïbes à travers de nombreux
stéréotypes véhiculés à partir du 19ème
siècle notamment l'île au trésor de
stevenson ou l'attraction pirates des
caraïbes de disneyland est devenu un
film d'art et on s'imagine des pirates
soudé au rhum borgne avec accrochée à la
place de la main un perroquet sur
l'épaule et c'est alors que je suis
quelqu'un de tout à fait normal et sûr
de ce que tu dis concernant ses idées
reçues je vais m'attarder sur le drapeau
de pirate qui n'apparaît en fait qu'au
xviiie siècle soit à la fin de l'âge
d'or de la piraterie et il s'agit en
fait d'un pavillon puisque c'est ainsi
qu'on appelle les drapeaux maritime et
son petit nom est le job et rogers le
thème de la tête de mort et des tibias
au sabre qu'on retrouve sur la plupart
de ces pavillons appartient au genre
artistique du memento mori qui est
utilisée depuis l'antiquité et qui
signifie souviens-toi que tu vas mourir
c'est gai c'est pas si sombre on peut
rapprocher cette formule du carpediem
une carte par jour accueille le jour qui
incite à profiter de la vie tant qu'on
ait envie
l'idée du jolly rodgers et donc de
profiter de la vie en faisant tout ce
qu'on veut dans l'art les natures mortes
sont un autre exemple très courant de
memento mori
mais pourquoi faire de la piraterie
c'est dangereux on court le risque
d'être tué pendu et la plupart des
pirates ne vivent pas très longtemps
et en plus ça rapporte pas tant que ça
alors pourquoi as tu déjà entendu parler
du commerce triangulaire nous soyons
l'état de navires qui sillonnent la mer
chargé de richesse ça n'existe pas ton
appétit d'accord vous voulez de l'or des
richesses mais au risque de faire un
raccourci un peu grossier le vol s'est
mal alors pourquoi tu connais dropt us
il a écrit le traité marc libéré sommes
en 1609 qui explique grosso modo que la
mer est à tout le monde alors la mer
à nous aussi et on y fait ce qu'on veut
ouais mais tu peux aussi être marin sans
passer par la case pirates
ouais j'ai essayé ça faut travailler
toute la journée obéir aux ordres on a
peine à manger mais j'ai essayé les
navires marchands j'ai vite changer de
camp quand on est piraté de bonheur on
est beaucoup plus libre moins de
contraintes tout le monde est heureux à
se plaint des conditions de travail la
petite pierre à tu essayes de servage
une journée on en reparlera vous
connaissez sûrement d'autres termes pour
qualifier des pirates des caraïbes
flibustiers boucaniers et bien il existe
des nuances entre ces termes les
boucaniers d'abord ont un rôle bien
spécifique puisqu'il s'agit de
communautés vivant sur l'île de la
tortue ou sur saint-domingue et qui
chasse le cochon ou le boeuf sauvage
puis qui le fûmes la viande
il pratique aussi le commerce de
couilles c'est tout pour la plupart il
s'agit de marins ou des esclaves en
fuite les populations pauvres de pirates
qui ont décidé de prendre leur retraite
il s'agit d'une forme de commerce en
marche qui repose en partie sur la
contrebande et c'est pourquoi elle est
associée assez rapidement à la piraterie
en plus les boucaniers fréquentent les
pirates puisqu'ils vivent dans les mêmes
espaces
il peut arriver un boucaniers
d'embarquer sur un bateau de temps faire
un petit peu de piraterie puis de
retourner chassaient le cochon leur
aventure prend fin à la fin du xviie
siècle où faute de gibier à tulle sont
obligés de se reconvertir mais j'utilise
le terme de pirates depuis tout à
l'heure je n'ai pas encore parlé des
flibustiers le mot flibustiers désigne
spécifiquement les pirates d'origine
française anglaise ou hollandaises qui
exercent en mer des caraïbes entre le
16e et le xviie siècle
leur nom vient du mot hollandais vries
buteur qui signifie qui fait son butin
librement donc en gros en langage
moderne je fais ce que je veux
iolo ce sont surtout les pirates
installés sur l'île de la tortue dont
j'ai parlé précédemment
quand je parlais des boucaniers qui
fréquentaient des pirates en fait ils
fréquentaient des flibustiers c'est le
français pierre blindé selon but qui
prend possession de l'île au xviie
siècle au détriment des espagnols qui
l'occupé rejoints par des anglais et des
hollandais les nouveaux occupants de
l'une il décide de se lancer dans la
flibuste flibusterie les gouverneurs
successifs de lille qui passe aux mains
des espagnols puis des anglais et puis à
nouveau des français continuent de
tolérer l'activité des flibustiers l'un
des gouverneurs français 2
levasseur accorde même des autorisations
aux flibustiers pour qu'ils s'attaquent
aux navires espagnols s'étaient pas la
grande entente
les flibustiers sont donc à mi chemin
entre le pirate le corsaire puisque leur
activité est un peu entre les deux et
comme précisé dans la première vidéo à
corsair est un pirate autorisé par un
état a exercé les vielles de port-royal
en jamaïque est de nassau aux bahamas
sont également d'importants repaire de
flibustiers on retrouve le pirate henry
morgann à port royal tandis que barbe
noire gouverne au nassau à partir des
années 1680 les flibustiers présent dans
les caraïbes sont chassés par les
français et les anglais et se disperse
certains vers les côtes africaines et
d'autres vers le pacifique flibustiers
boucaniers ont marqué l'histoire des
caries pendant un siècle et ceux
désignés sous le nom des frères de la
côte
la piraterie se développe ensuite dans
l'océan indien notamment autour de l'est
de madagascar où elle est alimentée par
les flibustiers qui ont fui l'île de la
tortue en mer de chine la piraterie se
développe à la même époque sous l'ère
ming à cette époque la chine connaît un
repli sur elle même le contact avec les
civilisations étrangères est interdite
et le commerce devient le monopole de
l'état tu m'étonnes que sa rentrée n'est
de la piraterie
la piraterie est le fait de plusieurs
personnages les tanks ad'abord sont des
paysans riches de la région de canton la
piraterie est également le fait de
japonais qu'on appelle les oies cauet
qui sont employés par des grandes
familles marchandes de canton mais la
piraterie en mer de chine diminue à
partir du xvième siècle l'empereur
améliore des défenses des villes
côtières et assoupli ses politiques
commerciales comme ça plus besoin de
pirates
cependant la chute de la dynastie ming
entraîne une résurgence de la piraterie
à partir de 1644 n'est pas de panique
a nouvelle dynastie met fin avant la fin
du xviie siècle
cela n'empêche pas la piraterie de
retour j'ai régulièrement à la fin du
xviiie siècle et au milieu du 19e siècle
alors bien sûr tout ça fait un peu rêver
la culture populaire nous vante des
pirates libre sans foi ni loi cool pour
ceux qui soupire de nostalgie en pensant
aux époques révolues qui se demandent à
quelle époque j'aurais aimé vivre elle
poc de la piraterie représente un sacré
potentiel de badass riz qui est mis en
valeur dans la littérature le cinéma et
les séries
merci de ne pas nous oublier ça me va
droit au coeur pourtant la piraterie
existe encore elle est même un sacré
augmentation si on en croit ce graphique
du bureau maritime international
comme depuis l'antiquité elle se
concentre dans les lieux de passage les
détroits et les canaux le long des côtes
on la retrouve surtout en mer des
caraïbes où elle est facilitée par
toutes les petites villes qui s'y
trouvent dans le golfe d'aden au
débouché du canal de suez
et enfin dans toute l'asie du sud est
avec une mention spéciale pour le
détroit de malacca
si on compare la piraterie à une carte
des principales routes maritimes
ça ce sont les attaques sont menées
contre des petits pétroliers ou des
méthaniers principalement afin de
s'approprier leur cargaison
en somalie les pirates s'attaquent aussi
à des navires de croisière pour
rançonner les touristes souvent fortunés
qui s'y trouvent
c'est le cas du ponant en 2008 où les
touristes sont retenus en otage pendant
huit jours avant d'être libéré contre
une rançon
la plupart des pirates ont été arrêtés à
leur retour en somalie les pirates
viennent de pays pauvres et se tourne
vers la piraterie parce que l'économie
de leur pays ne leur permet souvent pas
de faire autrement
de ce fait aussi des pays concernés par
la piraterie ne sont pas en mesure de
lutter efficacement contre ce phénomène
ne sont pas assez équipés n'ont pas les
moyens d'entretenir une flotte qui
surveillerait l'heure où la lutte contre
la piraterie et donc internationale elle
est le fait du bureau maritime
international de l'organisation maritime
internationale et d'interpol il existe
aussi un observatoire régional de la
piraterie à kuala lumpur et des
patrouilles qui ont été autorisés par le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu en somalie
et en malaisie et qui ont permis de
diminuer les attaques ces dernières
années je terminerai en mentionnant
l'intervention des dirigeants africains
au conseil de l'onu en 2009 qui lisait
que c'est une bonne chose d'aider à
lutter contre la piraterie mais que ça
serait sûrement encore plus efficace si
on s'occuper d'abord de régler les
problèmes de paix de sécurité et de
crises humanitaires que connaissent ces
pays et qui sont souvent à l'origine de
la piraterie
c'est vrai que tu veux qu'on parle de
tes problèmes ont mal jamais encourager
ça va
merci d'avoir regarder cet épisode on se
retrouve très bientôt pour du chronique
de profs ou pour du créatrice du tube je
ne sais pas encore en tout cas merci et
à bientôt
dida manager local